two people at the hospital after being
shot i'm denise valdez and i'm kirsten
joyce this happened near a busy
intersection in henderson the i-team's
vanessa murphy joins us live near the 5
15 and sunset with the latest vanessa
police say they're searching for the
shooter after two people were shot here
at the gas station we also learned there
was a two-year-old child nearby now
right now you can see it is business as
usual here at the gas station but
earlier this was an active crime scene
henderson police say this happened just
after one this afternoon and the two
victims transported themselves to the
hospital the two-year-old child was in a
nearby suv after her father says he
stopped to help break up a fight that's
before he knew there was a gun involved
here's the child's mother
it was just terrifying and i was
the first my first thought really was to
call the police so that someone could
come out and help out with the situation
um
and hearing not just my husband but
having my baby that close to something
like that was horrible
this area was blocked off by police for
more than three hours one witness says
the shooter was wearing a wendy's
uniform police and wendy's management
have not confirmed that but i'll show
you how close the restaurant is the gas
station right over here and then right
next door here's the wendy's again that
is not confirmed that's according to a
witness right now the restaurant is
closed reporting live vanessa murphy 8
news now